okay guys we're doing the mission the
way of the boys and we gotta speak to
some dry there is a grave it is so
dragonborn appears at this moment in the
turning of the egg yes I'm here we will
see a few truly show us dragonborn I
just taste of your voice he do that
shout at us let us taste
no boys
how do you
the foul
oh there we go we must be afraid your
shout not harm us a relief with every
charge shout at us let us taste of your
voice Oh dragon more it is you welcome
to I am master on you I speak for the
grey beard okay now tell me dragonborn
why have you come here we are here to
guide you in that pursuit just you are
not the first there have been many
whether you are the own you are the only
one that has been reviewed thus far
without training you have taken the
first steps towards projecting your
voice into a spoon salt now hey if you
are willing and able to learn IMA when
you shout you speak in the land was your
presence thus your dragon blood gives
you an inborn ability to learn words of
power all shouts are made up of three
words of power
as you master each word your shout will
become progressively stronger ack ack
Master I not will now teach you roll a
second word in unrelenting Ellen yet bro
means balance in the Dragon tongue
combine it with force force to focus
your two more shot the [ __ ] is that
ok
you learn a new word like a master you
truly do have the gift but learning a
word of power is only to try to activate
it mr. you must unlock its meaning to
constant practice in order to use it in
a shout well that is how the rest of us
the chance as Dragonborn you can absorb
a slaying dragons life force and
knowledge directly as part of your
initiation master I not will allow you
to tap into his understanding that Carol
today I do sure strike the target is
they appear at Chateau ha
personnel one welcome again haha katka
okay where's next one you learn quick
see what's more haha impressive your
film is precise you show great promise
Dragonball malaria we will perform your
next trial in the courtyard follow
master boring yeah
yeah question why do you guys live in
was a hellish place to be the side that
are you play up stuck here and it's
[ __ ] hard to get here dude
ok
we will ask me how you learn a
completely new master bari will teach
you would
the word with you before you could
protect you to have a baby now I could
do that yesterday my belly
magic
hasta Wulfgar will demonstrate whirlwind
sprint then it will be your turn now he
can't stand next to me Master bari will
open the gate use your whirlwind sprint
assume before I could get a gap
identified oh thank you oh yeah
your quick mastery of a new film is
astonishing I'd heard the stories of the
abilities of Graydon born but to see it
for myself
you are now ready for you retrieve the
Horn of Jurgen win column remain true to
the way of the horse tank and anchor